[Música]
un despliegue de orgullo nacional con el
icónico fuerte rojo de nueva delhi como
telón de fondo el primer ministro indio
narendra modi celebró la resiliencia de
su país en sus 75 años de independencia
y expuso su visión para el próximo
cuarto de siglo
tenemos que convertir a india en una
nación desarrollada durante nuestra vida
los jóvenes de 20 21 25 años que están
aquí delante de mí los jóvenes de mi
país cuando india celebre los 100 años
de independencia tendrán entre 50 y 55
años lo que significa que el periodo
dorado de sus vidas los 20-25 años de
sus vidas es el momento de hacer
realidad los sueños de indiano como pura
carne
de los hogares y las empresas de toda la
india han sido llamadas a enarbolar la
bandera nacional como parte de una
campaña patriótica del gobierno mientras
tanto los partidos de la oposición dicen
que fueron excluidos de las
celebraciones del día y acusan al
gobierno nacionalista de moody de
socavar las libertades democráticas y
religiosas del país en declaraciones a
france 24 embajador de india en francia
se mostró en desacuerdo con esa
valoración y use software solo hay que
ir a las librerías y ver cualquier
cantidad de libros que son a la vez
críticos con el gobierno críticos con
muchas cosas que todavía tenemos que
hacer para que nuestra democracia sea
más perfecta todas las religiones están
entretejidas en el tejido social tienen
garantías constitucionales el
clarinetista woody el propio modi no
respondió a las críticas en un discurso
de 80 minutos ni abordó los tensos lazos
de india con vecinos como pakistán los
dos países se independizaron al mismo
tiempo en 1947 tras el fin del dominio
colonial británico y el sangriento
período de la partición pakistán celebró
su independencia durante el fin de
semana el domingo uniformados de ambos
países celebraron una ceremonia conjunta
en su frontera